I'm going to show you how to disable
Wi-Fi and bluetooth using shortcuts on
iOS as some of you will be asking why do
I need to use some special methods
shortcuts when I have the control center
well the control center is great I use
it all the time but it has a problem if
you turn on Wi-Fi and Bluetooth by
pressing those toggles there then it
should connect to any networks as you
can see over in the top left or any
accessories which is great but if you go
back to control center and try to turn
them off in the same way you turn them
on it does save disconnecting and if you
have a look in the top bar there you can
see I'm no longer connected to Wi-Fi but
if you dig into the settings and have a
look at Wi-Fi the radio is actually
still on it's just not connected to any
network so I have to manually turn that
off it's the same deal over here with
Bluetooth the radio is still on
consuming battery I have to manually
turn that off so this is a bit of a
hassle if what you want to do is
conserve power instead of doing it
through the control center what I'm
going to do is use this new app on my
home screen that you can see called
shortcuts if I open that up it gives you
the opportunity to create different
little scripts or shortcuts that have
functions so if I create one here and if
I search for Wi-Fi you can see the
second option down set Wi-Fi is right
there and the green toggle is set to on
right now so if I press this shortcut at
the moment it would turn Wi-Fi on I
actually wanted to turn Wi-Fi off so I'm
gonna toggle that I'm also going to
customize this shortcut just a little
bit with this icon over here in the top
right hand side just below done if I
press on that I can give this a more
helpful name than untitled shortcut I
might call this Wi-Fi off and I will
also give it a more helpful icon
something like red for off let's select
a glyph that looks a little more like an
actual Wi-Fi symbol that one I'll do say
it done so if I create this now and say
done this shortcut if I activate it will
disable the Wi-Fi and do it properly
will actually turn off the radio which
is great now to put this in a place
that's easy to access what I'm going to
do is swipe left to go to my widget
screen and if I say edit I can add a
widget and if you scroll down a little
bit you can see that shortcuts is their
fifth from the bottom so I'm going to
press the green plus icon add it on and
press done and so now you can see I have
a new
short cut that's appeared which says
Wi-Fi off so let's give it a quick test
if my turn on Wi-Fi using the control
center like normal I twiddle my thumb's
for a second and then hopefully my Wi-Fi
actually connects there it is in the top
left hand corner so I'm not gonna use
the control center instead I'm gonna
swipe over left hit Wi-Fi off the
shortcut runs and sure enough in the top
left you can see Wi-Fi is disconnected
more importantly if I go to settings you
can see Wi-Fi is actually properly off
and so this is a really handy shortcut
for me I use it every day all the time
to conserve battery and I can do the
same thing for Bluetooth as well I can
say alright let's create a new one for
Bluetooth search for blue there it is I
don't want it to turn on I want it to
turn off and I also wanted to have a
more helpful name that's a bit
descriptive so I'm gonna call this one
bTW for Bluetooth off and I'll make it
red as well because it's off and I will
pick an icon that looks a bit Bluetooth
that why don't do it for me while I'm at
it because the control center might be
something that you find harder to reach
I know on the newer iPhones which are a
bit larger if your hands are small it's
hard to reach up to the top you can't
reach from the bottom because there's no
there's no home button so they've
replaced the control center from the
bottom with a control center at the top
so if you want Wi-Fi often blue to off
to be accompanied by the opposite
options say Wi-Fi on I can say this
Wi-Fi shortcut is now to keep things on
that's why the green toggle is there I'm
going to call this one I just should
before I leave it I should talk give it
a more helpful name let's call this one
Wi-Fi on and I'll make this one green
instead because green is more of an on
sort of car but there's the same icon
that I chose before and just for
completeness sake let's make a Bluetooth
on set Bluetooth make it a little more
helpfully labelled bluetooth on and I'm
gonna make it green with that same kind
of ikana chose earlier there it is
done alright now that I've created this
sort of nice little set here if I go
over to my widgets options all of them
appear so I can toggle the blue the
Wi-Fi on and it will connect I can
toggle it off I can toggle the Bluetooth
on from here as well if I had some
headphones or something like that they
might connect and you can see that by
the way there it is on on the control
center and if I say bluetooth off then
if I look back on the control center it
is truly off so hope you guys have found
that helpful and it's useful to you can
even get to them from the lock screen if
you like and I find this something
really handy see you guys